he grinds the rough edges creating a  smooth surface to weld the tube to the  rest of the roll cage  once complete the team transfers the  roll cage to the mainframe of the  chassis  they tack-weld it before doing the final  welds  the next part is called the rear clip it  holds the fuel tank and has mounts for  the rear suspension with the car  framework now complete  a technician scans it using a digital  measuring probe the scan confirms that  the dimensions are correct they now  assemble the various steel and carbon  fiber body parts to the stock car  framework  they measure the completed car body by  laying template grids on it the biggest  one sits over the center of the car they  pull a gauge through the gaps between  the templates and the car body the gap  cannot exceed the tolerance is set by  NASCAR they often must tweak the shape  of a body part to meet regulations